This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars and this is a message from the U.S. Forest Service. Trails take a beating every year from the elements and from heavy or improper use. You're listening to an excerpt from an official Forest Service video made in 1995. It's called Basic Trail Maintenance. As you might expect from something filmed in the 90s, this video features acid wash denim and a narrator dressed like Laura Dern from Jurassic Park. This video also contains some practical information for forest service employees and other trail workers
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯，这是一则来自美国林务局的消息。每年，自然因素以及沉重或不当的使用都会对步道造成破坏。你现在听到的是1995年林务局官方视频的节选，片名叫《基础步道维护》。正如你对90年代拍摄的视频所预期的那样，视频里出现了酸洗牛仔裤，还有一位穿着打扮像《侏罗纪公园》里劳拉·邓恩的旁白。这段视频还包含了一些供林务局员工和其他步道工作人员参考的实用信息，
about how to build in care for hiking trails. A good trail is one that is easy to follow and well maintained. Each trail is designed, constructed, and maintained to meet specific standards. These standards relate to the recreational experience the trail is intended to provide. I find this video delightful and not just because of the amazing soundtrack. It also takes the humble trail, something many of us take for granted, and deconstructs it. So over the next two episodes, we're going to do the same. We're going to show you some of the basics, things you can do to keep trails in good shape now and in the future.
关于如何建设和维护徒步步道。一条好的步道应该是易于辨认且维护良好的。每一条步道的设计、建造和维护都旨在满足特定的标准。这些标准与步道旨在提供的休闲体验有关。我觉得这段视频非常有趣，不仅仅是因为那令人惊叹的配乐。它还将平凡的步道——许多人认为理所当然的事物——进行了拆解。因此，在接下来的两期节目中，我们将做同样的事情。我们将向你展示一些基础知识，即你现在和未来可以做些什么来保持步道的良好状态。
We're bringing you two episodes of short stories, all about trails. I first read Robert Moore's book on Trails when it came out back in 2017, and I was immediately pulled in, not just by the writing, which is lovely, by the way, but also by Robert's attention to detail. He has this amazing way of drilling down into some of the smallest, most elemental questions about Trails, including possibly the most fundamental question of all. What even is a trail? It's hard to define, actually.
我们将为你带来两期关于步道的短篇故事。罗伯特·摩尔的《步道》一书在2017年出版时，我第一次阅读，立刻就被吸引住了，不仅是因为那优美的文笔，顺便提一下，还因为罗伯特对细节的关注。他有一种惊人的能力，能深入探讨关于步道的一些最微小、最本质的问题，包括可能最根本的问题。到底什么是步道？事实上，这很难定义。
I spend a lot of time thinking about that. This is Arthur Rubbermore. And I think that the key aspect of a trail is that a trail is a line that evolves. It's something that we follow where each time you walk, you're leaving a slight bit of yourself behind. And the next person who comes picks up on those signals that you're leaving and they leave their own signals. And over time, it keeps changing subtly.
我花了很多时间思考这个问题。这是亚瑟·拉伯摩尔。我认为步道的关键在于，步道是一条不断演变的线。它是我们跟随的路径，你每走一次，都会留下自己的一点痕迹。而下一个走过的人会捕捉到你留下的信号，并留下他们自己的信号。随着时间的推移，它会不断发生微妙的变化。
So let's say there's a big curve in the trail we'll take the inside of that curve and we'll shave it down and shave it down until it's a straight line. In a curious way, a trail is something that's both terrestrial and liquid. And that's what I find beautiful about them, unlike roads, you know, or especially railways
假设步道有一个大弯道，我们会走弯道的内侧，不断地修剪它，直到它变成一条直线。有趣的是，步道既是陆地的，又是流动的。这就是我觉得它们美妙的地方，不像公路，你知道，或者特别是铁路，
which are so fixed, you know, they're laid down in an almost authoritarian way. A trail is very collaborative and organic. Something that stands out for me in Robert's writing is the focus on the non-human world. To me, there's this sense that trails are deeply human creations. Like, when I think about a trail, I imagine someone bush-wacking a path through tall grass or hiking through the woods. But in fact, trail building is a tool that is nearly universal to life on Earth. On the smallest scale, I think a lot of animals are using trails as a form of externalized
它们是如此固定，你知道，它们是以一种近乎专制的方式铺设的。步道是非常协作且有机的。罗伯特的作品中有一点让我印象深刻，那就是对非人类世界的关注。对我来说，这传达出一种感觉，即步道是深刻的人类创造。比如，当我想到步道时，我会想象有人在长草中开辟路径，或者在树林中徒步。但事实上，步道建设是一种对地球生命几乎普遍适用的工具。在最小的尺度上，我认为许多动物都在利用步道作为一种外化的
intelligence. So, answer the most famous example. They leave behind these Pheremon trails which are invisible and yet these very simple signaling mechanisms, you know Just laying down a little bit more or a little bit less Pheremon Creates these incredibly intelligent Solutions to finding food Finding, you know, one another. It's it's quite incredible what they're able to do with just the very, very simple mechanism of, you know, follow me. Come this way. Don't go that way.
智能。所以，回答最著名的例子。它们留下了这些费洛蒙路径，它们是隐形的，然而这些非常简单的信号机制，你知道，只要多留下一点或少留下一点费洛蒙，就能创造出寻找食物、寻找彼此的极其智能的解决方案。它们仅凭“跟我来，走这边，别走那边”这种非常、非常简单的机制就能做到这一点，真是太不可思议了。
One of the most fascinating parts of Entrails is about a single-celled organism called slime mold. Robert writes about an experiment where scientists in Japan and England created a map of the most densely populated areas of Tokyo, with each key point marked by a cluster of food. Then they brought in the slime mold. What happened next is that, incredibly, the slime mold built a network of trails between the points that almost exactly mirrored Tokyo's actual railway system, a system which, by the way, is one of the most efficient in the world. The findings point to a shared logic of efficiency
《步道》中最迷人的部分之一是关于一种名为黏菌的单细胞生物。罗伯特写了一个实验，日本和英国的科学家绘制了一张东京人口最稠密地区的地图，每个关键点都用一簇食物标记。然后他们引入了黏菌。接下来发生的事情是，令人难以置信的是，黏菌在这些点之间建立了一个步道网络，几乎完全复制了东京实际的铁路系统，顺便说一句，该系统是世界上最高效的系统之一。这些发现指向了一种共享的效率逻辑，
that has informed cross species trail building for millennia. If you think about how we were building trails before the advent of hiking trails, what was happening was we were collaborating with animals. When humans were walking across the landscape, we were following the trails that were laid out by deer or bison or in Africa. Oftentimes they follow elephant trails.
这种逻辑几千年来一直影响着跨物种的步道建设。如果你思考一下我们在徒步步道出现之前是如何建设步道的，你会发现我们当时是在与动物合作。当人类在景观中行走时，我们跟随的是鹿、野牛开辟的路径，或者在非洲，它们通常跟随大象的路径。
Those were well known to be the best routes across a landscape. Found the chalous Ford across a river or the chalous pass across the mountains. All of these animals were collaborating and you'll still see it today. I go trail running every weekend and we'll often see a black bear ambling down the trail. Well, that's because that's the path of least resistance.
众所周知，那是穿越景观的最佳路线。找到了穿越河流的浅滩或穿越山脉的山口。所有这些动物都在合作，你今天仍然可以看到这一点。我每个周末都会去越野跑，经常会看到一只黑熊沿着步道漫步。嗯，那是因为那是阻力最小的路径。
Yeah. So we're all working together on the landscape to create a really vast map of trails that covers the whole continent. As Robert tells it, this desire for the path of least resistance is what unites the human and non-human world in our trail building. But it's also where human trails set themselves apart. Where animal trails almost always find the most efficient route between resources, our own trails are determined by another set of rules entirely. The modern hiking trail is the most illogical thing you can imagine from a sheer efficiency
是的。所以我们都在景观上共同努力，创造了一张覆盖整个大陆的巨大步道地图。正如罗伯特所说，这种对阻力最小路径的渴望，正是将人类和非人类世界在步道建设中联系在一起的原因。但这也是人类步道与众不同的地方。动物步道几乎总是找到资源之间最高效的路线，而我们自己的步道则完全由另一套规则决定。现代徒步步道从纯粹的效率角度来看，
standpoint. We go up to the highest mountains, we follow these really tortuous paths that no animal or really most indigenous societies would have followed. And the reason why is because we're following our own cultural values. We're looking for a beautiful vista. We're looking to challenge ourselves against, you know, this rough wilderness. We're doing things that a sheer efficiency equation would never predict.
是你所能想象的最不合逻辑的东西。我们登上最高的山峰，我们走这些真正蜿蜒曲折的路径，没有任何动物或大多数土著社会会走这些路。原因在于我们遵循的是我们自己的文化价值观。我们在寻找美丽的景色。我们寻求在粗犷的荒野中挑战自我。我们做的事情是纯粹的效率公式永远无法预测的。
Another word is our modern hiking trails are built following a logic that is uniquely inefficiently human. It's a task that brings along with it a whole grad bag of considerations about what makes a trail not only functional, but pleasurable for the people who are going to be using it. This brings us to our second trail story.
换句话说，我们现代的徒步步道是遵循一种独特且低效的人类逻辑建造的。这是一项任务，它带来了一整套关于什么使步道不仅功能齐全，而且对使用者来说令人愉悦的考量。这把我们带到了我们的第二个步道故事。
From 99 PI producer, Kurt Colstead. Hey Kurt, so usually you're the train guy, but today you're all about trails. What kind of trail story do you have for me? Well, Roman, when I was a kid, my dad, who was a professor of geophysics, used to take field trips of grad students to the black hills of South Dakota each year. And he'd take me along some years, too. We'd hike up and down these trails, digging and zagging our way through the trees. And I remember feeling, at the the time like these paths looked natural.
来自99PI制作人库尔特·科尔斯特德。嘿库尔特，通常你是火车专家，但今天你全是关于步道的。你有什么样的步道故事要讲给我听？嗯，罗曼，当我还是个孩子的时候，我父亲，一位地球物理学教授，每年都会带研究生去南达科他州的黑山进行实地考察。有些年份他也会带上我。我们会在这些步道上上下下，在树林中蜿蜒穿行。我记得当时感觉这些路径看起来很自然。
Like we were treading where animals had walked for millennia. But that childhood guess of mine, that these were ancient pathways was way off the mark. Because those black hills trails and pretty much every other trail you've ever walked on is anything but natural. Okay, explain what you mean by that. I mean that across the nation tens of thousands of miles of trails managed by state and federal governments, including everything from local trails to high profile hikes like the Appalachian Trail and the Pacific Crest Trail,
就像我们走在动物几千年来走过的地方一样。但我那个童年的猜测，即这些是古老的路径，完全错了。因为那些黑山步道，以及你走过的几乎每一条其他步道，都绝非自然。好吧，解释一下你的意思。我的意思是，在全国范围内，由州和联邦政府管理的数万英里步道，包括从当地步道到像阿巴拉契亚步道和太平洋屋脊步道这样备受瞩目的徒步路线，
they're all engineered, built, and heavily designed to maintain a sort of naturalistic illusion, creating a quote wilderness experience for visitors. Right, right. Like they just kind of happened. Yeah, exactly. Like maybe some wild animal just happened to be tramping back and forth and create this narrow trail between, say, a parking lot and this lake near the parking lot that visitors want to visit.
它们都是经过工程设计、建造和精心设计的，旨在维持一种自然主义的幻觉，为游客创造一种所谓的“荒野体验”。对，对。就像它们只是自然而然形成的。是的，完全正确。就像可能某种野生动物正好来回踩踏，在停车场和游客想要参观的湖泊之间开辟了这条狭窄的步道。
I guess the relief for doing this for us that, you for us, that animals anticipated our parking needs very much so. So how does this all work? How do you create these naturalistic trails? I mean, I picture these interns hiding the forest, they scatter some stones, they put leaves on paths so that we know where we're going. I mean, it sounds silly, but that's much closer to the truth than you might imagine. In fact, it sounds silly, but that's much closer to the truth than you might imagine.
我想我们这样做是为了让我们觉得动物预料到了我们的停车需求，确实如此。那么这一切是如何运作的呢？你如何创造这些自然主义的步道？我的意思是，我脑海中浮现出实习生躲在森林里，撒些石头，在路径上放些树叶，这样我们就知道该往哪里走了。我的意思是，这听起来很傻，但这比你想象的要真实得多。事实上，这听起来很傻，但这比你想象的要真实得多。
In fact, the job of making sure that trails feel natural falls to a whole bunch of people. You've got National Park Service employees, biologists, psychologists, spotinists, planners, designers. And then of course, you do have the on-the-ground trail workers who execute this vision. Okay, so what exactly are folks doing
事实上，确保步道感觉自然的工作落到了一大群人身上。你有国家公园管理局的员工、生物学家、心理学家、植物学家、规划师、设计师。当然，还有在现场执行这一愿景的步道工作人员。好吧，那么人们到底在做什么
to create the illusion of a naturalistic trail? Well, it all starts at the beginning when they're clearing the trail and I first learned about how extensive a project this could be from a fan of the show who wrote in, named Kelly Heat Warren, and she introduced me to her boss, a program director at the US Forest Service named Mike McFadden.
来创造自然主义步道的幻觉？嗯，这一切始于清理步道之初，我第一次了解到这个项目可以有多么广泛，是从一位写信给节目的粉丝凯莉·希特·沃伦那里得知的，她把我介绍给了她的老板，一位在美国林务局工作的项目主管，名叫迈克·麦克法登。
And between them, I started to learn about some really fun trail-building techniques with interesting names like the Velvet Hammer. Okay, so what is the technique of the Velvet Hammer? Well, the idea is that trail workers are going to make an impact. That's inevitable, and that's the hammer part. But they can be deliberate and careful about reducing the visibility of that impact, and that's the velvet part. And what does this look like in practice? So, for example, Mike McFadden told me that one method involves using colored flags. When establishing a new trail, he and his crew would deploy a line of yellow flags to mark the path of that trail that they're
在他们之间，我开始了解一些非常有趣的步道建设技术，有着像“天鹅绒锤”这样有趣的名字。好吧，那么“天鹅绒锤”是什么技术？嗯，这个想法是步道工作人员会产生影响。这是不可避免的，这就是“锤子”的部分。但他们可以深思熟虑且小心翼翼地减少这种影响的可见度，这就是“天鹅绒”的部分。这在实践中是什么样子的？所以，例如，迈克·麦克法登告诉我，一种方法涉及使用彩色旗帜。在建立新步道时，他和他的团队会部署一排黄色旗帜来标记他们正在
working on. But they'll also put down red flags next to bushes or shrubs they want to preserve and make sure to work around. So take a sapling for instance that workers want to preserve. They might use a string to bend it out of the way and then later cut that string, letting it bounce back into place. And then other times they'll uproot and replant entire shrubs if, you know, avoiding them or bending them is just too tricky. And when it comes to trails, we're talking about, in some cases, dozens of workers all camping for weeks on the site. So trail workers also have to mitigate the impact of their own presence.
工作的步道路径。但他们也会在他们想要保护并确保绕过灌木或灌木丛旁边插上红色旗帜。比如，以工作人员想要保护的一棵树苗为例。他们可能会用一根绳子把它弯到一边，稍后再剪断那根绳子，让它弹回原位。还有其他时候，如果避开或弯曲它们太棘手，他们会连根拔起并重新种植整个灌木。当谈到步道时，在某些情况下，我们谈论的是几十名工作人员在现场露营数周。所以步道工作人员也必须减轻他们自身存在的影响。
McFadden has another hack for leaving no trace in these situations, which he calls the reverse dog departure. Okay, what is that? So you know when a dog is going to lay down, they often circle the spot, look, gain, sniff, figure around before curling up. This is like that, but in reverse. Crews are supposed to circle their campsite as they pack up and leave, making sure no wrappers or other artifacts are left behind.
麦克法登在这些情况下还有另一个“不留痕迹”的妙招，他称之为“反向狗离开”。好吧，那是什么？所以你知道当狗要躺下时，它们经常会绕着那个点转圈、观察、嗅探、弄清楚，然后再蜷缩起来。这就像那样，但反过来。工作人员在收拾行李离开时应该绕着他们的营地转圈，确保没有包装纸或其他人工制品留下。
And they take this pretty far. The final step as he explained it to me was that you get up and the place where you're sitting you basically kick dirt over your own butt prints so that even that becomes invisible in your wake. So I'm starting to get an idea of the scope and scale here, which I don't think I really fully pictured. Even if I had grown to accept that these trails were not natural and took some effort to make, I had no idea how much they were to serbbing to create them and then how much they had to
他们做得相当彻底。正如他向我解释的那样，最后一步是你站起来，把你坐的地方基本上用泥土盖住你自己的屁股印，这样即使是那个在你身后也会变得不可见。所以我开始对这里的范围和规模有了一个概念，我想我之前并没有完全想象出来。即使我已经接受了这些步道不是自然的，并且需要一些努力来制造，我也不知道他们为了创造它们需要付出多少努力，以及事后他们需要
remediate after the fact. Yeah, it's really remarkable. And McFadden gave me the example of a two-foot wide trail requiring up to a 20-foot wide impact corridor, which is a lot to mitigate. And so keeping existing features helps maintain the illusion of this thing being older and not being clear cut. And other little detail work helps, too, like turning over rocks so that they're weathered side face up or moving phone logs near the pathways. That kind of thing.
进行多少修复。是的，这真的很了不起。麦克法登给了我一个例子，一条两英尺宽的步道需要长达20英尺宽的影响走廊，这需要付出很多努力来减轻。因此，保留现有的特征有助于维持这种东西更古老且没有被砍伐的幻觉。其他细节工作也有帮助，比如翻转岩石，使它们风化的一面朝上，或者移动路径附近的倒木。诸如此类。
I mean, how common is it for a trail to get this kind of no stone unturned treatment? Well, as you might imagine, it's the most heavily used trails that get the treatment like this, right? The smaller trails get less because the bigger the trail, the more popular trail is the more this kind of effort is required to go in and offset all of that impact being made by all of those hikers. And to keep that trail feeling much more untouched by humans, then it really is. We have talked about this. Like I know that wilderness isn't natural as such.
我的意思是，步道得到这种“不放过任何一块石头”的处理有多普遍？嗯，正如你可能想象的那样，正是那些使用最频繁的步道得到了这样的处理，对吧？较小的步道得到的处理较少，因为步道越大，步道越受欢迎，就需要投入越多的这种努力来抵消所有那些徒步旅行者造成的所有影响。并保持那种步道感觉比实际更少受到人类的影响。我们已经讨论过这个问题了。就像我知道荒野本身并不自然。
It's a, you know, kind of human construct, but still this level of staging, like 20 feet wide swath to create a two foot wide trail, I mean, that means you're hiding 90% of your impact on the forest when you make a trail. Yeah, it's super impressive. And the whole endeavor reminds me a lot of theatrical set design. You know, the careful staging of this backdrop,
它是一种，你知道，某种人类的建构，但这种程度的布置，比如20英尺宽的条带去创造一条两英尺宽的步道，我的意思是，这意味着当你建造步道时，你隐藏了你对森林90%的影响。是的，这令人印象深刻。整个努力让我想起了很多戏剧布景设计。你知道，这种背景的精心布置，
all for the benefit of an audience, and this audience doesn't end up seeing most of the behind the scenes work that goes into the show. If they're doing the job right, these creators effectively erase signs of their own creative efforts to maintain this illusion for you. But you know, feeling natural is only like one aspect of a trail, I mean, fundamentally what you need to have a trail work is for the trail to bring you from point A to point B. Yeah.
一切都是为了观众的利益，而这些观众最终并没有看到演出背后的大部分工作。如果他们工作做得对，这些创造者有效地抹去了他们自己创造性努力的痕迹，为你维持这种幻觉。但你知道，感觉自然只是步道的一个方面，我的意思是，从根本上说，你需要步道发挥作用，就是让步道把你从A点带到B点。是的。
Yeah. How do they make that work? A lot of trails actually goes into subtly communicating how to get from point A to point B and also how not to get to point C. So part of what it means for a trail to work is that it diverts people away from hazards like precarious cliffs or places that they're not supposed to go like private property. Well, also bringing hikers where they want to go
是的。他们是如何做到这一点的？很多步道实际上都在微妙地传达如何从A点到达B点，以及如何不到达C点。所以步道发挥作用的一部分意义在于，它将人们从危险的地方（如不稳定的悬崖）或他们不应该去的地方（如私人财产）引开。同时也将徒步旅行者带到他们想去的地方，
to scenic overlooks and waterfalls, that sort of thing. Because if the trail doesn't take them to those, you can bet that people will trample through the forest and get there anyway. Yeah, totally. So the big picture is for a trail to be successful. It avoids the bad and dangerous places. And also takes you to good places so that you can take pictures for Instagram.
比如风景优美的观景点和瀑布，诸如此类。因为如果步道不带他们去那些地方，你可以打赌人们会践踏森林并无论如何都会到达那里。是的，完全正确。所以大局是，为了让步道成功，它避开了糟糕和危险的地方。同时也带你去好的地方，这样你就可以拍照片发到Instagram上。
That's where things. So yeah, avoid the bad, take you to the good, and do it all with a set difficulty level that is specific to each trail. So that might involve steeper slopes, but it can sometimes even involve rolling rocks or logs onto a trail to keep up its difficulty quotient. Okay, so you're saying that if something has a known difficulty rating, they will purposely put hazards in the way to make that trail difficulty rating. They will purposely put hazards in the way to make that trail difficulty consistent.
这就是事情所在。所以是的，避开坏的，带你去好的，并且以特定于每条步道的设定难度级别来完成这一切。所以这可能涉及更陡峭的斜坡，但有时甚至涉及将岩石或原木滚到步道上以保持其难度系数。好吧，所以你是说如果某样东西有已知的难度等级，他们会故意在路上设置障碍来使那个步道难度等级。他们会故意在路上设置障碍来使那个步道难度保持一致。
That's correct. And it really kind of boom, I mean, this was like the last rabbit hole I fell down with this project. I was like, no way. It's just, you know, you could spend the lifetime on this stuff. Yeah.
没错。这真的有点，砰，我的意思是，这就像我在这个项目中掉进的最后一个兔子洞。我当时想，没门。这只是，你知道，你可以在这些东西上花一辈子。是的。
Well, I'll remember that next time I'm like sweating and panting as I hold myself up a boulder because somebody did this to you. Somebody did this to me. It wasn't nature. It was just, that's right. That's somebody in the wilderness. This is awesome, Kurt.
好吧，下次我气喘吁吁地把自己撑上一块巨石时，我会记住这一点，因为有人为你做了这个。有人为我做了这个。那不是大自然。那只是，没错。那是荒野里的某个人。这太棒了，库尔特。
Thank you so much. I'm gonna have so much fun decoding and sort of like looking for the visual language of trails next time I walk on. Awesome! Our next story comes to us from 99PI listener Joelle McNichol, who sent us a voice memo from her local hiking trail in the craggy north of England. Hi there, this is Joella and listening from Colterdale in Yorkshire in the north of England. Big fan of the show. I thought I'd record you this while I'm out on my dog walk, which is where I normally
非常感谢。下次我走的时候，我会很有趣地解码并寻找步道的视觉语言。太棒了！我们的下一个故事来自99PI听众乔尔·麦克尼科尔，她从她位于英格兰北部崎岖地区的当地徒步步道发来了一段语音备忘录。你好，我是乔拉，正在英格兰北部约克郡的科尔特代尔收听。我是节目的忠实粉丝。我想在遛狗时为你录下这段话，这通常是我
listen to the show. So I just thought while I'm out on this walk I would record a short one about the very woods that I'm walking through. It's a beautiful valley, it's got very steep sides with moors on the top and great deep hillsides with great big craggy rocks and the whole valley is studded with these tall round chimneys, many of which just pop up in the middle of the woods halfway up a hillside. All of them are remnants of the industrial past of the valley when it was full of cotton mills.
收听节目的时间。所以我只是想在这次散步时录一段关于我正在穿过的树林的小故事。这是一个美丽的峡谷，两侧非常陡峭，顶部有荒原，深邃的山坡上有巨大的崎岖岩石，整个峡谷点缀着这些高大的圆形烟囱，其中许多只是在半山腰的树林中间冒出来。它们都是峡谷工业过去的遗迹，当时这里到处都是棉纺厂。
And Chris crossing this wood is an incredible number of footpaths which represent so much labor and work. There's great stone sets cut right into the hillside. And it just seemed kind of senseless because there's so many of these paths really close together. There's one point where six paths meet in one place, like a junction, like a sort of, you know, great big motorway junction of the footpaths in the middle of the woods. So I was like, why on earth was all this effort put in to make these footpaths. And I've just found out and it's a really interesting story.
在这片树林中纵横交错的是数量惊人的小路，它们代表了如此多的劳动和工作。山坡上直接切割出了巨大的石阶。这看起来有点毫无意义，因为有这么多小路靠得非常近。有一个地方，六条小路汇合在一起，就像一个交叉路口，就像树林中间步道的一个巨大的高速公路交叉口。所以我当时想，为什么人们要费这么大劲去修这些小路呢？我刚刚发现，这是一个非常有趣的故事。
So in 1862, most of the mill workers were refusing to work, they were refusing to work in factories, because they didn't want to use the cotton that was being imported from the slave plantations in America. There was huge support for abolition of slavery in this area. There were a lot of cooperative businesses, there was a lot of Quakers. There was such a big industry here, such a big market for American cotton that it helps contribute to the end of the civil war. So you had this sort of, you know,
所以，在1862年，大多数工厂工人拒绝工作，他们拒绝在工厂工作，因为他们不想使用从美国奴隶种植园进口的棉花。该地区对废除奴隶制有巨大的支持。这里有很多合作企业，有很多贵格会教徒。这里有如此大的产业，对美国棉花有如此大的市场，以至于它有助于促成内战的结束。所以你有这样一种，你知道，
quite a long patch of time where the workers were refusing to work in the mills. And so some of the philanthropic employers found other things for those workers to do. And one of the things that they did was to employ them to build all of these paths. And so yeah, this is a sort of surprising history of these crazy paths in my woods.
相当长的一段时间，工人们拒绝在工厂工作。因此，一些慈善雇主为这些工人找到了其他事情做。他们所做的事情之一就是雇佣他们去建造所有这些小路。所以是的，这是我树林里这些疯狂小路的一种令人惊讶的历史。
Anyway, it just struck me as a 99 PI type of mini story, and I thought I would record it for you as I walk. And yeah, hope you found it interesting. Bye, thank you. region of England on the west coast, bordering Scotland to the north, it contains the Lig District National Park and lots and lots of mountains, or Fels as they're known locally. It's also where I grew up before I moved to Toronto. That's reporter Jay Copern. On a shelf at my parents' house in Cumbria are the seven faded books. Honestly, they look a bit like something out of Lord of the Rings. If you open them up, you won't find any type setting. Just handwritten texts, along with meticulously detailed pen and
总之，这让我觉得这是一个99 PI类型的迷你故事，我想我在散步时为你录下来。是的，希望你觉得它很有趣。再见，谢谢。英格兰西海岸的一个地区，北邻苏格兰，它包含湖区国家公园和许许多多山脉，或者当地称为“Fells”。这也是我在搬到多伦多之前长大的地方。那是记者杰伊·科伯恩。在我父母位于坎布里亚的房子里的架子上，有七本褪色的书。老实说，它们看起来有点像《指环王》里的东西。如果你打开它们，你找不到任何排版。只有手写的文字，以及对风景和当地山脉各种路径的极其详细的钢笔和
ink drawings of the scenery, and various paths up the local mountains. This set of seven books make up a pictorial guide to the Lakeland Fals by Alfred Wainwright. The books were published between 1953 and 1966 and have become a staple for many comrades, as well as for tourists to the area. Even today, GPS is useful, but a book doesn't need a battery, and there's nothing quite like a carefully drawn illustration. These books have become so popular that the 214 Lake District peaks in their pages are actually known as wainwrights.
墨水画。这套七本书构成了阿尔弗雷德·温赖特所著的《湖区山脉图解指南》。这些书出版于1953年至1966年间，已成为许多同伴以及该地区游客的主食。即使在今天，GPS很有用，但书不需要电池，没有什么比精心绘制的插图更好的了。这些书变得如此受欢迎，以至于书页中的214座湖区山峰实际上被称为“温赖特”。
Wainwright Aill is served in pubs, including one in the tourist town Kessik. The pub is called, you guessed it, the wainwright. For decades now, hikers in the Lake District have been finding their way through the fells of Cumbria mainly by following one grumpy old dude's writings up a hill. When we talk about England being a little green island, it really is. It's much greener than most places. Oh god yeah. Land of mist and mellow fruitfulness.
温赖特艾尔啤酒在酒吧供应，包括旅游小镇凯西克的一家。这家酒吧的名字，你猜对了，就叫“温赖特”。几十年来，湖区的徒步旅行者主要通过跟随一个脾气暴躁的老家伙写的一本书上山，在坎布里亚的山脉中寻找方向。当我们谈论英格兰是一个绿色的小岛时，它确实是。它比大多数地方都要绿得多。哦，天哪，是的。迷雾和醇厚果实的土地。
This is a different, less grumpy old dude. Russ Coburn, aka my dad. All my way in right knowledge is from him. There are very few signposts once you're up the fells and indeed most fell walkers if you to ask them would be against that. They would say no that's all the point. The point is adventure. The point is finding you way and navigating.
这是一个不同的、不那么脾气暴躁的老家伙。拉斯·科伯恩，也就是我爸爸。我所有的温赖特知识都来自他。一旦你上了山，几乎没有路标，事实上，大多数山地步行者如果你问他们，他们会反对这一点。他们会说，不，那才是重点。重点是冒险。重点是寻找你的道路和导航。
When I was back home in December I could jolt him through a rickety gate into a field full of sheep and mud to follow Wainwright's directions up one of the smaller hills known as Sailfell. Wainwright described it as the cornerstone of the North Western Fells because it sits at the end of the western end of Bassen's Waite Lake where the River Drow went to returns more. I'm not sure I'd realised how different hiking is in the UK to North America before I moved to Toronto, Canada, where I live now.
当我在十二月回家时，我可以带他穿过一扇摇摇欲坠的门，进入一个满是羊和泥土的田野，沿着温赖特的指示爬上一座较小的山，称为Sailfell。温赖特将其描述为西北山脉的基石，因为它位于巴森斯韦特湖的西端，德罗温特河在那里返回更多。在搬到我现在居住的加拿大多伦多之前，我不确定我是否意识到英国的徒步旅行与北美有多么不同。
In North America, hiking often feels a bit like organized fun. You drive to a parking lot with a nice laminated maps and toilets and a well maintained path. Everything is color coded with explicit signage and markers. You get the idea. But back home in Cumbria, you pick a fail from a Wainwright guide, and you get some scrappy directions to a muddy path behind a barn, winding its way through Bracken and Farmland, and you hike the way Wainwright hiked, with no trailheads, just some chicken scratch in an old book. If I open up book six, the Northwestern Fells, and turn to Sailfell, there are no page numbers,
在北美，徒步旅行通常感觉有点像有组织的娱乐。你开车到一个有漂亮的层压地图、厕所和维护良好的路径的停车场。一切都用明确的标牌和标记进行了颜色编码。你明白了。但在坎布里亚的老家，你从温赖特指南中挑选一座山，你会得到一些关于谷仓后面泥泞小路的草率指示，蜿蜒穿过蕨类植物和农田，你以温赖特徒步的方式徒步，没有步道起点，只有旧书里的一些鸡爪字。如果我打开第六本书《西北山脉》，翻到Sailfell，没有页码，
by the way, there are sketches of the Withert Valley, with sheep silhouetted in the foreground. Here's a passage about the local deer, which praises the forestry commission for tolerating them and a little jab at the hunters who don't. And here's a drawing of the ruins of a church to use as a landmark for directions. I think if you picture it and it helps you to set in your mind the sort of topography of where you're going.
顺便说一句，有Withert山谷的素描，前景中剪影着羊。这是一段关于当地鹿的段落，赞扬林业委员会容忍它们，并对不容忍它们的猎人进行了一点讽刺。这是一幅教堂废墟的画，用作方向的地标。我想如果你想象它，它有助于你在脑海中设定你要去的地方的地形。
And you know, you'll be walking up to me. Oh yeah, he said said there's this tree here Or there's this waterfall here and it sort of brings it all into So context Because they are very very detailed These books are printed on rugged paper with wide margins so you can scribble notes They're designed to be taken hiking up muddy hills in Cumbrian weather People come to the lake this in complain that it was cloudy and it rained,
而且你知道，你会走到我面前。哦，是的，他说这里有这棵树，或者这里有这个瀑布，它在某种程度上把它都带入了背景，因为它们非常非常详细。这些书印在坚固的纸上，留有宽大的页边距，所以你可以乱涂笔记。它们被设计成可以在坎布里亚的天气里带着去泥泞的山上徒步。人们来到湖区抱怨说天气多云而且下雨，
but rather points out the fact that that's why it's called the Lake District, because it rains. The Wainwright Guides are the way they are in every way, because of who Alfred Wainwright was, the way he wrote was typical of his personality, solitary and cramudgenely. His writing is blunt, often opinionated, but very appreciative of the fell's stark beauty. Let me read you what he wrote about another peak called Ling-Fel.
但温赖特指出了这就是为什么它被称为湖区的事实，因为它下雨。温赖特指南在各方面都是现在的样子，是因为阿尔弗雷德·温赖特是谁，他写作的方式是他个性的典型，孤独且脾气暴躁。他的写作直率，经常有主见，但非常欣赏山脉的荒凉之美。让我读给你听他写的关于另一座名为Ling-Fel的山峰。
Gloomy and sulky, even on the sunniest of days, its lack of visual appeal, however, belies its nature. For the easy slopes and comodious top are extremely pleasant to wander upon. As you might expect from someone who spent his life wandering hills alone, he was more than a bit introverted. He described himself as anti-social, and that he'd rather be alone. He wouldn't even say hello to other solo walkers on the fails. Right now you're probably picturing a greyhired man with a flat cap, pipe, glasses, and mutton chops. This is entirely accurate." His obsession with the lake district began when he was 23 and he saved up five pounds to go walking for a week. As he says here,
即使在阳光明媚的日子里也阴沉而闷闷不乐，然而，它缺乏视觉吸引力掩盖了它的本质。因为平缓的斜坡和宽敞的顶部在上面漫步非常令人愉快。正如你对一个一生独自漫步山丘的人所预期的那样，他不仅仅是有点内向。他形容自己是反社会的，他宁愿独自一人。他甚至不会对山上的其他独行者打招呼。现在你可能正在想象一个灰头发、戴着平顶帽、烟斗、眼镜和羊排胡须的男人。这完全准确。”他对湖区的痴迷始于他23岁时，他存了五英镑去徒步旅行了一周。正如他在这里所说的，
on the long-running BBC Radio Show, desert island discs. at island discs. By all accounts he was an unusual man. He preferred silence to music, and he survived on a diet almost entirely made up of fish and chips. He hated the idea of traveling abroad and never once boarded a plane or boat. No ambition to travel abroad. I couldn't finish the customs and the new currency and the foreign language and the foreign food and the passport. Wayne Wright didn't even want to publish his work at first, and when he did, he got a friend to help because he couldn't face finding a publisher himself.
在长期播出的BBC广播节目《荒岛唱片》中。荒岛唱片。据所有说法，他是一个不寻常的人。他喜欢沉默胜过音乐，他靠几乎完全由炸鱼薯条组成的饮食生存。他讨厌出国旅行的想法，从未登上过飞机或船。没有出国旅行的野心。我无法完成海关、新货币、外语、外国食物和护照。温赖特起初甚至不想出版他的作品，当他这样做时，他找了一个朋友帮忙，因为他自己无法面对寻找出版商。
Despite all that, he hand-wrote and illustrated seven intricate volumes in 13 years. Wainwright was not someone who enjoyed the fame he found. He had moved to Kendall in the South Lakes and got a job at the town hall. He got a salary from that, but he wasn't rich, and all his book royalties went to animal charities. From there, Alfred Weinwright kept up his solitary hiking as millions of copies of his guides made their way into circulation, onto rural English shelves and into muddy backpacks, torn, worn, and rain soaked in many fell walkers' jacket pockets. Despite his wish to remain solitary, you can still find Wainwright in his guides. When he reads his books, the roots often start in the middle of a village or town, because that's where the
尽管如此，他在13年内手写并绘制了七卷复杂的书。温赖特不是一个享受他所获得的声誉的人。他搬到了南湖区的肯德尔，在市政厅找了一份工作。他从中得到了一份薪水，但他并不富有，他所有的版税都捐给了动物慈善机构。从那里，阿尔弗雷德·温赖特保持着他的孤独徒步，数百万册他的指南进入了流通，进入了乡村英国家庭的书架，进入了泥泞的背包，在许多山地步行者的夹克口袋里被撕裂、磨损和雨水浸透。尽管他希望保持孤独，但你仍然可以在他的指南中找到温赖特。当他阅读他的书时，路线通常从村庄或城镇的中间开始，因为那是
bus stop or train station was. Wainwright took public transport everywhere. I suspect he also didn't like the idea of spoiling the piece and quiet with the roar of a car. Now there are even some hikers dedicated to doing all 214 fails how Wainwright did them, using only public transport. Collecting the peaks or Wainwright bagging is a common practice in Cumbria, and you can find Facebook groups and Instagram accounts where Walker's document their progress. Wainwright died in 1991, and these walks are one way he's remembered,
公共汽车站或火车站所在的地方。温赖特到处乘坐公共交通工具。我怀疑他也不喜欢用汽车的轰鸣声破坏宁静的想法。现在甚至有一些徒步旅行者致力于像温赖特那样完成所有214座山峰，只使用公共交通工具。收集山峰或“温赖特装袋”是坎布里亚的一种常见做法，你可以找到Facebook群组和Instagram账户，步行者在那里记录他们的进度。温赖特于1991年去世，这些徒步旅行是他被记住的一种方式，
but they're far from the only way. And the village of Buttermeer, nestled between the peaks of Grassmore and Haystacks, is a low stone church. Inside it is a plaque. It reads, pause and remember Alfred Wainwright, Fell Walker, Guidebook author and illustrator who loved this valley. Lift your eyes to Hastax, his favorite place.
但这远非唯一的方式。在坐落在Grassmore和Haystacks山峰之间的Buttermeer村，有一座低矮的石教堂。里面有一块牌匾。上面写着，停下来记住阿尔弗雷德·温赖特，山地步行者，指南书作者和插画家，他热爱这个山谷。抬起你的眼睛看向Hastax，他最喜欢的地方。
Our final trail story, at least for today, is after the break. Our final trail story, at least for today, is after the break. Our final trail story today comes from reporter Chris Barubay. Chris, what do you have for us? Well Roman, a couple years ago, I was visiting my grandma in Montreal and that's where my hiking story comes in. So is grandma a big hiker? She's 92 years old, so no, it's not about her.
我们最后的步道故事，至少在今天，在休息之后。我们最后的步道故事，至少在今天，在休息之后。我们今天最后的步道故事来自记者克里斯·巴鲁贝。克里斯，你有什么要告诉我们的？嗯，罗曼，几年前，我正在蒙特利尔探望我的祖母，这就是我的徒步故事的由来。那么祖母是一位伟大的徒步旅行者吗？她92岁了，所以不，这不是关于她的。
She's very active for a 92 year old, but this is a story about me attempting to hike. Okay. So I'm not much of a hiker, but I was hoping to get into it, and I had this free morning in Montreal, so I decided to hike up Mount Royal. So Mount Royal, it's this mountain in the middle of the city.
对于一个92岁的老人来说，她非常活跃，但这关于我尝试徒步旅行的故事。好吧。所以我不是一个徒步旅行者，但我希望能开始，我在蒙特利尔有一个空闲的早晨，所以我决定徒步登上皇家山。所以皇家山，它是城市中间的这座山。
It has this summit with a beautiful view, it kind of oversees everything. And there's also a park in the mountain that was designed by Frederick Law Olmstedt. Yes, the designer of Central Park, yeah. The designer of Central Park, that's right. I highly recommended it if you're ever in Montreal, check it out. And I had done this walk up Mount Royal, actually a lot of times when I was a kid. So there was some nostalgia for me, but I couldn't really remember how to get
它有一个拥有美丽景色的山顶，它俯瞰着一切。山上还有一个由弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德设计的公园。是的，中央公园的设计师，是的。中央公园的设计师，没错。如果你在蒙特利尔，我强烈推荐你去看看。我实际上在小时候多次走过皇家山。所以我有一些怀旧之情，但我真的记不起怎么去
on to the trail. So I type in Mount Royal Summit on my phone and my phone directs me to this entrance and at the entrance There's this big wooden staircase and that was kind of surprising like I had no memory of this big wooden staircase So it's a mystery staircase. It is a true mystery staircase. So I start climbing up. Okay. I'm like, okay You know probably the staircase will drop me off at the trail at some point So I'm going up, I'm like, okay, you know, probably the staircase will drop me off at the trail at some point. So I'm going up a flight of stairs and there's a landing. And then you go up another flight of stairs
步道了。所以我把“皇家山山顶”输入我的手机，我的手机把我引导到这个入口，在入口处有一个巨大的木制楼梯，这有点令人惊讶，因为我对这个巨大的木制楼梯没有任何记忆。所以这是一个神秘的楼梯。这是一个真正的神秘楼梯。所以我开始往上爬。好吧。我想，好吧，你知道，可能楼梯会在某个时候把我送到步道上。所以我往上走，我想，好吧，你知道，可能楼梯会在某个时候把我送到步道上。所以我走上一段楼梯，有一个平台。然后你走上另一段楼梯
and there's another landing. And then another flight of stairs and there's another landing. And after a couple of minutes, I'm starting to wonder if there's ever going to be a way off the staircase because so far there hasn't been an exit. Oh no. And there's no sign suggesting that you're going to get off it at some point.
有一个平台。然后又是一段楼梯，有一个平台。几分钟后，我开始怀疑是否会有离开楼梯的方法，因为到目前为止还没有出口。哦，不。而且没有任何迹象表明你会在某个时候离开它。
So after about five minutes, I like to think I'm in pretty good shape, but I'm not used to climbing that many stairs. Sure. I'm starting to sweat a little. You know, it's a really hot day. And I'm just climbing and climbing. And at some point, I decided, OK,
所以大约五分钟后，我喜欢认为我的身体状况很好，但我习惯不了爬那么多楼梯。当然。我开始出汗了。你知道，这是一个非常炎热的日子。我只是在爬啊爬。在某个时候，我决定，好吧，
maybe I should just start recording myself like for my loved ones, I guess, if I never get off the staircase. About 10 minutes into a walk, and I see no end in sight. So Roman, at some point I'm starting to wonder if I'm ever going to get off the staircase. Yeah, yeah, that's fair.
也许我应该开始录下自己，比如为我的亲人，我想，如果我永远无法离开楼梯的话。步行大约10分钟，我看到没有尽头。所以罗曼，在某个时候，我开始怀疑我是否永远无法离开楼梯。是的，是的，这很公平。
Well, I assume you made it off at some point. No, I'm calling you from the staircase. I've been recording there for the past several years. No, I kept going, I kept going, I kept going, I get up to the top of the staircase, and at this point I'm sweating, and I'm wondering like, what happened? So I take out my phone, and I pull up a map of Mount Rayao,
好吧，我假设你在某个时候离开了。不，我正从楼梯上给你打电话。我在那里录音已经好几年了。不，我继续走，我继续走，我继续走，我走到楼梯顶端，此时我汗流浃背，我想知道，发生了什么？所以我拿出手机，调出皇家山的地图，
and everything becomes clear really quickly, because on the map, on one side, there's this nice, gentle-looking trail, the Olmstead trail, that's the one that I remember from being a kid. But instead, I went the other way, and it took me up this staircase, which is evidently what I ended up taking. Now, I could have avoided this if I had spent more than,
一切很快就变得清晰了，因为在地图上，一边有一条看起来不错、平缓的步道，奥姆斯特德步道，那是我小时候记得的那条。但我走了另一条路，它带我上了这个楼梯，显然我最终走了这条路。现在，如果我花的时间超过，
like, 10 seconds looking at my phone, and just going, okay, I'll go this way. So I'm embarrassed, but the phone did tell me to go that way. And do you know why your phone sent you up this sort of second round? Well, the trail takes quite a while, takes over an hour, and the staircase, it takes about 20 minutes from the street.
比如，10秒钟看我的手机，只是说，好吧，我会走这条路，我就能避免这种情况。所以我很尴尬，但手机确实告诉我走那条路。你知道为什么你的手机把你送到这个第二轮吗？嗯，步道需要相当长的时间，需要一个多小时，而楼梯从街道出发大约需要20分钟。
So my guess is my phone looked at these options and it was like, okay, this is the fastest way up. So it just sent me the fast way up. Now look, ultimately this was not a bad thing for me. You know, I got some exercise, things turned out fine, but I'm not the only person who has made this mistake of relying on my phone when I was hiking. And it's actually been a much bigger problem for other people. There's been a number of stories of people using Google maps specifically, or folks that are using apps that are more geared, I would say, to car navigation. So this is Wesley Trimble, and he used to work as the creative director for the American Hiking Society.
所以我猜我的手机看了这些选项，它就像，好吧，这是最快的上去方式。所以它只是把我送到了最快的上去方式。现在看，最终这对我也不是坏事。你知道，我得到了一些锻炼，事情结果很好，但我不是唯一一个在徒步旅行时依赖手机而犯这个错误的人。这实际上对其他人来说是一个更大的问题。有许多关于人们专门使用谷歌地图的故事，或者使用更倾向于汽车导航的应用程序的人。所以这是韦斯利·特林布尔，他曾经在美国徒步旅行协会担任创意总监。
We hear stories all the time of people saying, I want to go to the top of Sush and Sush Mountain. And it just basically says, all right, like, here's the point A to point B, which can put people into some great harm because the shortest route is almost never the best route. So that's how you end up with something like taking a never-ending staircase. Or there's so many cases that are just so much worse. So there's a story from a couple of years ago in Scotland where Google Maps was creating this path for hikers on Ben Nevis. That's this 4,500-foot mountain. And it was creating this path that it went off trail. It was telling hikers to climb over this kind of very steep rocky terrain, and mountaineering
我们经常听到人们说，我想去某某山的山顶。而地图软件基本上就是说，好的，这是从A点到B点的路线，这可能会让人们陷入巨大的危险，因为最短的路线几乎从来都不是最好的路线。这就是为什么你会最终走上像永无止境的楼梯那样的路。还有很多情况要糟糕得多。几年前在苏格兰发生过一件事，谷歌地图为本尼维斯山的徒步旅行者规划了一条路径。那是一座4500英尺高的山。它规划的路径偏离了步道。它告诉徒步旅行者翻越这种非常陡峭的岩石地形，这属于登山范畴
Scotland had to get involved. And they called the trail potentially fatal, so Google ended up changing it. There's just so many stories of hikers getting lost or taking these weird routes because the mapping software is telling them where to go. So if you're hiking, especially if you're in a new place, using the built-in map on your phone is probably not a good idea, because they're just not designed for that.
苏格兰政府不得不介入。他们称这条步道有潜在的致命危险，所以谷歌最终修改了它。有太多关于徒步旅行者迷路或因为地图软件指引他们去哪里而走上奇怪路线的故事。所以如果你在徒步旅行，特别是在一个陌生的地方，使用手机内置的地图可能不是一个好主意，因为它们根本不是为此设计的。
So what should people do instead? Well, there are all these mapping apps that you can download that are actually designed for hiking. So maybe you've heard of all trails. That's the most popular version of that. Yeah. But Wesley told me there are problems with some of those apps as well. Some apps use user-generated data. In that case, the trail information is only as good as the person who put it there. One of the problems with crowd sourcing an app like this is that a lot of more experienced hikers will go on and they will often put in something called rogue trails.
那么人们应该怎么做呢？嗯，有很多你可以下载的地图应用程序，它们实际上是为徒步旅行设计的。也许你听说过AllTrails。那是其中最受欢迎的版本。是的。但韦斯利告诉我，其中一些应用程序也存在问题。有些应用程序使用用户生成的数据。在这种情况下，步道信息的准确性完全取决于提供信息的人。众包这类应用程序的问题之一是，许多经验丰富的徒步旅行者会上去，他们经常会输入所谓的“流氓步道”。
So these are animal trails or DIY trails or basically something that is not maintained by an official person. So nobody's going in and making sure that these are safe. And either these are kind of dangerous for inexperienced hikers or sometimes nature comes in and will disrupt trails like that. So is there any way to make sure that you have an accurate map when you're hiking? Well, the best thing to do, according to Wesley,
所以这些是动物路径、自制路径，或者基本上是没有官方人员维护的路径。所以没有人去确保这些路径是安全的。这些路径对缺乏经验的徒步旅行者来说很危险，或者有时大自然会介入并破坏这样的路径。那么，在徒步旅行时，有什么方法可以确保你有一张准确的地图吗？嗯，根据韦斯利的说法，最好的办法是，
according to the American Hiking Society, even if you're using one of those trail apps, have a backup. So get a paper map and a compass and learn how to use them. So on the official website for the American Hiking Society, it says, in bold letters, take a map and a compass, even on short-day hikes, don't tempt fate. That's amazing.
根据美国徒步旅行协会的说法，即使你正在使用其中一个步道应用程序，也要有一个备份。所以准备一张纸质地图和一个指南针，并学习如何使用它们。在美国徒步旅行协会的官方网站上，用粗体字写着：即使在短途日间徒步旅行中，也要带上地图和指南针，不要拿命运开玩笑。这太棒了。
So have you taken to this? Like, do you bring a map and a compass with you when you go on your hikes around Montreal? Since the staircase incident, no. I have not gone outdoors. Yes, I'm sensitive. You've learned your lesson. I've learned my lesson.
那么你采纳这个建议了吗？比如，你在蒙特利尔周围徒步旅行时会带地图和指南针吗？自从楼梯事件后，没有。我再也没有去过户外。是的，我很敏感。你吸取了教训。我吸取了教训。
I mean, this is a situation where I want to get into hiking, but Roman, I think I'm old enough now I have to accept who I am, which is somebody who stays home and makes podcasts. That sounds good. To the benefit of us all. Well, thank you so much for your time, Frischin. Thanks, Roman. Thanks, Roman.
我的意思是，这是一种我想开始徒步旅行的情况，但罗曼，我想我已经到了必须接受自己的年纪了，那就是一个待在家里做播客的人。听起来不错。这对我们所有人都有好处。好吧，非常感谢你的时间，弗里申。谢谢，罗曼。谢谢，罗曼。
Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Thanks, Frischin. Well, now you know some of the basics.
谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。谢谢，弗里申。好吧，现在你知道一些基础知识了。
Once you actually construct or maintain a trail, you will never look at one the same way again. This is the end of part one of our trail, special part two is coming next week. See you then. 99% invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, Coburn, Vivian Leigh, Kurt Colstag, Loshamadon, and Kelly Prime, edited by Kelly Prime, music by director of Sound Swan Rale, Sound Mixed by Martin Gonzales. Fact checking by Sona Avakin.
一旦你真正建造或维护过一条步道，你就再也不会以同样的方式看待它了。这是我们步道特辑第一部分的结尾，第二部分将在下周播出。到时候见。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝、科伯恩、薇薇安·李、库尔特·科尔斯塔格、洛沙马顿和凯利·普莱姆制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，声音总监斯旺·拉尔配乐，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦金完成。
Delaney Hall is their senior editor, our intern is Anna Castanero. Residine includes Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Morris. The 9% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, and beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can
德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑，我们的实习生是安娜·卡斯塔内罗。制作团队包括杰森·迪里昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格和我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以
tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Run Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. God ord. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在推特上@罗曼·马尔斯，或者@99PI org。还有Instagram、Reddit和TikTok。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。上帝啊。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。